I wanted it to be something iconic well
that's basically beyoncé's middle name
the 38 year old formation singer made a
surprise appearance at the Tyler Perry
studios grand opening gala on Saturday
rocking an iconic floor-length braid and
glittering gown Queen Bee was simply
glowing in this long sleeve at custom
Joseph's al jazmyne beaded gown which
she paired with Annabel Chan and jewelry
a gorgeous red lip and that braid that
went all the way down to her ankles very
inspiring he shared a few pics from the
event on Instagram congratulating and
praising Tyler in the caption writing in
part I could feel our ancestors presence
surrounded by my heroes it makes me so
proud so full I could not stop crying
you inspire me to dream even bigger from
your mouth of God he was with Beyonce's
mom at Tina Knowles Lawson and her
husband Richard all on the red carpet
where they dished on possibly opening
their own studio you all are doing your
own thing like this in LA will you do
something like will you eventually build
something like this and have your own
what goes through your mind when you see
this in how long till y'all do this well
we do it in June but I mean I'm so
excited about this I'm so proud of this
whole operation of Tyler and the strides
he's made and how he's giving people
jobs this just means more to us than
just this beautiful event but what he's
accomplished it's amazing isn't it
[Music]